[Music]
For generations, farmers have relied on
the sun to nourish their crops. Now,
with solar irrigation systems, you can
harness the sun's power to water your
fields sustainably. Imagine reducing
your reliance on expensive and polluting
fossil fuels while ensuring a reliable
water supply for your crops, even during
droughts. This is the promise of solar
irrigation, a technology transforming
agriculture and empowering farmers
worldwide. Solar irrigation is not just
about saving money on energy. It's about
investing in a greener future for your
farm and the planet. By switching to
solar, you contribute to a healthier
environment and reap the rewards of
increased crop yields and a more
resilient farming
[Music]
operation. A solar irrigation system
uses solar panels to power a pump that
draws water from a well, lake, or other
water sources. It's a simple yet
effective way to irrigate your crops
using a free and abundant energy source,
the sun. Instead of relying on the
electrical grid or diesel generators,
you generate clean electricity on your
farm, reducing your carbon footprint and
operating costs. These systems are
designed to be efficient and reliable,
providing the water your crops need when
they need it, even in remote areas
without access to the grid. Solar
irrigation is a smart investment for
farmers looking to embrace sustainable
practices and enhance their farm's
profitability.
A solar irrigation system comprises a
few key components working together to
deliver water to your crops. Solar
panels are the heart of the system,
converting sunlight into electricity.
The size and number of panels you need
depend on your irrigation needs and the
amount of sunlight your location
receives. The pump draws water from the
source and delivers it to the fields.
Solar irrigation systems typically use
specialized pumps designed for optimal
performance with solar energy. Think of
the controller as the brain of the
system. The controller regulates the
flow of electricity from the solar
panels to the pump, ensuring efficient
operation and protecting the system from
damage. The water source could be a
well, lake, river, or reservoir. The
type of water source influences the pump
and system design you'll need.
Understanding these components and how
they work together is essential for
selecting the right solar irrigation
system for your farm and ensuring its
optimal performance.
[Music]
Types of solar irrigation systems
tailoring to your needs. Just like crops
have different water requirements, solar
irrigation systems come in various types
to suit diverse farming needs and
geographical conditions. Drip irrigation
systems. These systems deliver water
directly to the plant roots through a
network of tubes and emitters,
minimizing water waste and maximizing
efficiency. Sprinkler systems. Ideal for
larger fields. Sprinkler systems spray
water over crops, simulating natural
rainfall. They offer flexibility and can
be customized to suit different field
layouts. Submersible systems. As the
name suggests, these systems use pumps
submerged in the water source, making
them suitable for drawing water from
wells, lakes, or rivers. Flood
irrigation systems. While less water
efficient than other methods, flood
irrigation can be suitable for specific
crops and terrains where water is
abundant. Choosing the right type of
solar irrigation system depends on
factors like your crop type, soil
condition, water availability, and
budget.
Benefits for farmers. Cost savings,
sustainability, and increased yields.
Switching to solar irrigation offers
numerous benefits for farmers, making it
a wise investment for the present and
the future. Reduced energy costs. Say
goodbye to fluctuating fuel prices and
high electricity bills. Solar irrigation
significantly reduces or even eliminates
your reliance on grid electricity or
diesel generators, leading to
substantial savings in the long run.
Sustainable farming. Solar energy is
clean and renewable, reducing your
farm's carbon footprint and contributing
to a healthier environment. Increased
water efficiency. Many solar irrigation
systems, particularly drip irrigation,
deliver water directly to plant roots,
minimizing water waste and improving
water use efficiency. Improved crop
yields. Consistent and reliable
irrigation leads to healthier plants and
higher crop yields, boosting your farm's
productivity and profitability. Remote
area accessibility. Solar irrigation
systems can operate independently of the
grid, making them ideal for farms in
remote areas with limited
infrastructure. By embracing solar
irrigation, farmers can save money,
conserve water, increase yields, and
contribute to a more sustainable future
for agriculture.